how how is your mini golf game it normal
on a normal course
it's pretty good uh on this course i'd
be i'd be soaking wet within seconds
i love that you're like i would fail um
all right well do you
i'm just wondering do you have like a
putter a cup you know a golf ball handy
anything like that would you be
maybe willing to bet me twenty dollars
you can sink a ten foot putt
i'm just saying uh challenge acceptance
accepted okay i can't wait to watch you
miss
all right hold on i gotta see if i can
get this going here
all right oh my gosh i can't play golf
at all
can you see the uh yes picked up
yes okay i'm gonna give a shot here okay
oh my gosh i could end it popped it
rejected your ball it's like oh no
does it count just kidding it counts
that's amazing i can't i can't put i was
still
my friend and i any time like next time
we go golfing i'm like i'm really good
at like i'm happy gilmore i can nail i
could launch a ball
but i just can't putt for anything
you're amazing that was awesome you got
to do team golf then you got to do team
golf get somebody can putt
that's what i'm going to do subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going